One of the considerations you have for
wearables is that some
watches are round,
and this is a new screen shape that
has never been dealt with before.
So if you're designing a wearable app,
you could have a round watch, or
a square watch.
There are two ways to deal with this.
You could design separate layouts for
round, and square watches.
Or you could design everything for
a square, and use what we call a box
insert layout to ensure that the content
always fits within the circle.
The down side is that it wastes
this space, on the edges.
The nice part about box insert
layout is that it provides a box for
your app to draw in, and
it promises that it will never make
the square leak outside the round area.
There is a sample code
delayed confirmation,
that uses box insert layout.
Let's start the sample up.
File.
Import Sample.
Delayed Confirmation.
Next.
And then,,
create the sample with the defaults.
The sample is a bit tricky to run,
since it was not meant to be used
without the phone app triggering it off.
You cannot run it,
using the green play button like usual.
If you try to run it, it'll prompt you
to select the default activity, but
it can't find one.
This is the error
message that you'll get.
So to fix this, we need to load
up the Android manifest file, and
make a correction.
We add android exported equals true for
the activity, and
now it will be able to be found.
So we're going to run it,
we also specify the default activity.
So we select the Main Activity here,
and now we can run it on the device.
We select that device, and we hit OK.
So you can see there's an added padding
to the top for the round display, but
not anywhere else.
Let's open up the layout
main_activity.xml.
You can see there is an app
layout box equals top here.
If you change it to all,
it will box all sides of the display.
If you set it to none, or
forget to add this,
the box insert layout will do nothing.
So, make sure you get this right.
Let's run it again, now.
After making this change, you can see
it working, and now boxing all sides.
An easy, but inefficient way of
designing is to always design for
a round shape, and
never ever put anything in any
of the corners on the edges.
This is easy because you only
need to maintain a single layout.
However, the downside is that the unused
corners on the square watch might look
weird, and it waste a lot of space.
So, this is probably not a great idea.
Finally, the most complete way
to do layouts for round and
square, is to use WatchViewStub.
This layout will inflate
either the rectLayout, or
the roundLayout depending
on the screen shape.
You can specify two
separate layout files, and
do a completely independent layout for
both types.
The sample that we compiled, and
ran at the start of this lesson used
WatchViewStub to show either hollow
round world, or hollow square world.
The catch with this layout is that you
need to carefully maintain both layouts,
making sure that the same IDs
are present in both files.